can we go to the mind of vladimir putin
because what you just said
china india
they seem to
sit back and say we're not going to
condemn the actions vladimir putin and
russia
but we would really like for this war to
be over
so there's that kind of energy
of we don't just stop this because
you're putting us in a very very bad
position and yet
vladimir putin is continuing the
aggression
what is he thinking what information is
he getting
is it the system that you've described
of authoritarian regimes that corrupts
your flow of information your ability to
make clear-headed decisions
um just as a human being when you go to
sleep at night
is he not able to see the world clearly
or is this all deliberate
systematic action that does
have some reason behind it
we got to talk a little bit about china
too but let's answer your putin question
directly
so
on twitter
you've lost the war
or as they say you know there are these
two russian soldiers having a smoke and
warsaw
and you know they're they're taking a
break having a smoke and they're sitting
there in warsaw on top of their tank and
one says to the other yeah you know we
lost the information war
and there they are sitting in warsaw
having that smoke right
so here on twitter russia has completely
lost the war
in reality they failed to take care they
failed to capture kiev
and they failed in phase two as they
called it
or plan b
which is to capture the entirety of the
donbass
we're three months into the war
if you had made a judgment about let's
say the nazi invasion of the soviet
union a definitive judgment after three
months
you might have got the outcome wrong
there
if you were judged the winner war the
1939-40 soviet invasion of finland
after three months
you would have got that wrong too of
what the outcome was going to be so
we're early in the game here
and we have to be careful about any
definitive judgments
but it is the case that so far
they failed to take care of and they
failed to capture the entirety of the
donbas luhansk and donetsk provinces
eastern ukraine
a part of eastern ukraine
and they've been driven out of
kharkiv and in the area immediately
surrounding heart keefe
they never captured heart keith but they
came close but now
the ukrainians drove them back to the
russian border in that very large and
important region
so those look like battlefield losses
that are
impossible to explain away
if you're the regime in russia except by
suppression of information
and as you know from russian history
likes
leaders in russia have an easier time
with the state of siege
and deprivation
than they do with explaining a lost war
but
let's look at some other
facts that are important to take into
account
one
the russian army has penetrated father
into ukrainian territory since february
2022.
including in here son region
the famous mariuple siege that just
ended
they have
built
a large
presence
in areas
north of crimea
on the sea of azov the black sea
littoral ultimately that they didn't
previously hold
they're still fighting in lukansk for
full control over at least half of the
don boss
and ukrainians are resisting fiercely
but nonetheless
you can say
that they've been driven out on the
contrary
farther penetration than the beginning
ukraine doesn't have an economy anymore
they have somewhere between 33 and 50
unemployment it's hard to
measure unemployment in a war economy
but their metallurgical industry that
azov style
steel plant and marijuana is a is a ruin
now
and a lot of farmers are not planting
the fields because the harvest from the
previous year still hasn't been
sent sold abroad because the ports are
blockaded or destroyed
and so you don't have an economy and you
need 5 billion or seven billion or eight
billion dollars a month
ex to meet your payroll
to feed your people to keep your army in
the field
that's a lot of money
per month and that's indefinite that's
as long as this blockade lasts
and so you don't have an economy anymore
you're indigent
and even if you take the lower number
five billion as opposed to zelinski's
ask for seven billion
five billion is 60 billion a year that's
60 billion this year that's 60 billion
next year
and so who's got that kind of money
which western taxpayers are ready
and if you use the 7 or 8 billion you
get up to 100 billion a year
the biden
uh the just signed the by uh president
joe biden just signed
the bill making it law
uh 40 billion dollars in aid to ukraine
it's just an enormous sum
the economic piece of that
is a month and a half two months
of ukrainians
uh
covering ukrainian expenditures that's
it
and they're asking the g7 they're asking
everybody for this so you have no
economy and no prospect of an economy
until you evict the russians from your
territory
and then you have
a western unity
western resolve it lasts or it doesn't
last lex
so you're president putin
and you've got
more territory than before
and you've got a stranglehold over the
ukrainian economy
and you've got a lot of the world
neutral
and you've got the chinese propaganda
supporting you to the hilt
with those oliver stone and mere shimer
lines
about how this is really nato's fault
and
you've got hungary
dragging its feed on the oil embargo
against russia and you got turkey
dragging its feed on the recent
applications
of sweden and finland for nato expansion
you're saying to yourself lex maybe i
can ride this out
i got a lot of problems of my own and we
can go into the details on the russian
side's challenges
but he's got
uh he's he's on ukrainian territory
unless he's evicted and he's got a
stranglehold on their economy and he's
got the possibility
that the west
doesn't stay resolved and doesn't
continue to pay for ukraine's economy or
supply those heavy weapons
and so you could argue that maybe he's
deluded about all of this
and maybe he should go on twitter you
know i'm not on twitter but maybe putin
who famously doesn't use the internet
should go on twitter and see he's losing
the war
or you can argue that maybe he's
calculating here
that he's got a chance to still prevail
you